we teamed up with etsy to show you easy
and unique ways
to personalize your pad well i am here
now with etsy trend expert dana ice and
johnson
what do we got here today dana all right
so we're going to talk about the hottest
things to have in your home for 2021 i
love this
the first thing that i'm going to talk
about is the wiggly squiggly decor
we've seen searches increase 28
236 percent on etsy people are searching
for it as wiggling and squiggling
i love it okay what else we got all
right so now we're going to move on to
etsy's color of the year which is skye
blue i love it and i'm stealing this
pillow steal it it's just for you
so now we're going to take it to
entertaining outdoors
come on outdoors let's go
i spy so many things i like here etsy is
really the destination to find
all of the items that are handcrafted
vintage customized that really fit
your personal style good i have a little
surprise for you oh i like a surprise
heard i heard some things on the street
oh boy so let me let me show you the
last surprise
come on okay
i wanted to make sure that we gave you
something to give you that personalized
touch
so let's see what we got okay i love a
surprise let's see what is this
oh it says this is the best
thing ever oh i'm so glad you like it so
this is a wonderful example of how you
can work directly with an etsy seller
get it personalized to exactly what you
want to make your house a real home